[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo l'émission qui revient
sur les temps forts de l'actualité à
l'assemblée et au sénat on va encore
parler aujourd'hui des conséquences de
l'épidémie de covin 19es avec moi pour
présenter cette émission tam tran huy
bonjour ta main bonjour brigitte on est
notre invité aujourd'hui marie noëlle
lienemann bonjour rocheuse est sénatrice
de paris et cette âme qui brosse votre
portrait marie noëlle lienemann vous
êtes né à belfort mais votre carrière
politique vous amener sur d'autres
terres vous a fait bourlingué du
pas-de-calais à la capitale en passant
par l'essonne vous êtes sénatrice de
paris depuis maintenant huit ans situés
à la gauche de la gauche vous avez
appartenu en tant que ministre du
logement a deux gouvernements
socialistes
au début des années 90 sous mitterrand
et au début des années 2000 gouvernement
de lionel jospin
mais il ya deux ans vous quittez le ps
avec fracas le parti que vous qualifiez
de canard sans tête
alors vous situez vous aujourd'hui
pourquoi est ce que vous n'avez pas
clairement franchi le rubicon jusqu'à la
france est soumise à ce que ce ne sont
pas les seuls audible aujourd'hui à
gauche
alors d'abord nous avons créé avec
emmanuel maurel et nos amis du mrc qui
étaient proches de jean-pierre
chevènement à partie parce que nous la
france est soumise n'est pas un parti un
parti chez nous peut-être la gauche
républicaine et socialistes pourquoi
parce que nous croyons partie comme
outil qui permet des synthèses politique
des réflexions collectives qui s'inscrit
dans la durée dans une histoire et dans
l'avenir
donc nous pensons que la gauche
républicaine manque aujourd'hui de
visibilité et doit mieux s'affirmer
je ne suis pas non plus quand vous dites
la gauche de la gauche je dirais que je
suis au coeur de la gauche parce
qu'historiquement on a quand même vu le
parti socialiste dériver vers le centre
quand je suis sympathique et vers le
libéralisme en tout cas moi je me sens
fidélité les parties sociales avec de
déplacés ben oui la preuve c'est que la
plupart des français considèrent qu'il
est plus à gauche
donc voilà donc mois à partir de ce
moment là si j'avais pensé qu' on
pouvait encore transformer ce parti qui
se dévitalise ecc avait quand même
permis l'arrivée d'emmanuel mâcon j'y
serais resté pour continuer mon combat
est aujourd'hui je vais une bruyante à
gauche je suis pour le rassemblement de
toute la gauche sans exclusive
or aujourd'hui j'observe gauche et
écologistes
l'émergence du monde écologiste
j'observe aujourd'hui que tantôt un
certain nombre de gens disent toute la
gauche sur jean luc mélenchon je
m'excuse c'est quand même lui qui est
encore aujourd'hui incarne la plus
grande force dans cette dynamique là et
de l'autre côté
peut être une tentative ou une tentation
de considérer qu'on peut faire sans une
partie de la gauche réformiste à
condition qu'on ait fait n'y ait pas
d'ambiguïté qui manuel macron donc je
suis pour le rassemblement autour d'un
programme offensif alors vous restez
avec nous voici tout de suite les types
de cette émission l'état d'urgence
sanitaire s'arrêtera le 10 juillet mais
le gouvernement prévoit ensuite une
sortie progressive un régime dérogatoire
pendant quatre mois qui fait grincer des
dents dans l'opposition il y avait déjà
deux commission d' enquête sur le coût
vide lancé par l'assemblée et le sénat
voilà que le gouvernement peut aussi
lancer sa propre évaluation de la crise
la crise économique succède à la crise
sanitaire un troisième projet de loi de
finances a été adopté en conseil des
ministres cette semaine
il porte l'effort financier à 460
milliards d'euros
et pour commencer cette émission
arrêtons nous sur le projet de loi
organisant la fin de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
[Musique]
la date est fixée l'état d'urgence se
termine le 10 juillet mais il ya un mais
car un projet de loi présenté mercredi
en conseil des ministres prévoit qu'il
soit suivi par un régime dérogatoire
jusqu'au 10 novembre
une période de quatre mois pendant
laquelle le gouvernement à pouvoir
restreindre certaines libertés
un autre de critiques un certain nombre
de sénateurs sanaa de sheer dans un mois
la france sortira de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
mais pas forcément du régime d'exception
dans un projet de loi présenté mercredi
en conseil des ministres le gouvernement
prévoit de maintenir certaines mesures
de restriction des libertés pour quatre
mois supplémentaires soit jusqu'au 10
novembre
le conseil scientifique a fait état de
quatre scenarii d'évolution de
l'épidémie dans tous ces scénarii le
virus existent toujours tant que nous ne
disposons pas de traitement aux deux
vaccins il continue donc à circuler même
à bas bruit et il est donc nécessaire
que nous soyons armée pour pouvoir
répondre à cette situation
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
n'avons pas souhaité qu'il y ait une
sortie sèche de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
mais plutôt une sortie en biseau pour
une période transitoire de quatre mois
jusqu'au 10 novembre l'exécutif pourra
donc réglementer la circulation des
personnes
l'accès aux transports en commun et aux
lieux accueillant du public mais surtout
il pourra continuer de limiter ou
d'interdire tout rassemblement sur la
voie publique
pour l'opposition c'est une prolongation
de l'état d'urgence qui ne dit pas son
nom bien en prolonge l'état d'urgence
parce que la situation sanitaire le
justifie ou bien on le prolonge pas nous
allons entendre les informations
scientifiques sur l'état de l'épidémie
et nous verrons bien à ce moment là ce
que nous déciderons mais en tout cas
nous prendrons une décision
frange pas dans un entre deux le projet
de loi sur la fin de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire doit maintenant être adopté
par le parlement et au sénat la partie
semble pour l'instant mal engagée pour
le gouvernement et pour la présidente de
la commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale et à yale brawn peavey il est
nécessaire de sortir progressivement de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire en écoute à
l'idée c'est de faire une feinte d'état
d'urgence sanitaire progressive on ne
peut pas tout arrêté d'un coup et puis
il faut envisager la possibilité que
une zone où une autre sur le territoire
il y est peut-être une recrudescence de
cette épidémie donc il faut garder quand
même certains outils donc ce projet de
loi vise à cela on arrête l'état
d'urgence d'une façon globale mais on
conserve un certain nombre d'outils ce
d'autant plus qu'on va rentrer en
période estivale
il faut plutôt que le premier ministre
le gouvernement et les outils à
disposition pour pouvoir agir
immédiatement si besoin
donc voilà c'est organiser la sur la
sortie de façon progressive raisonner en
assurant la sécurité juridique des actes
qui pourront être pris au moment de
cette sortie et puis voilà on termine
tranquillement cette période cette drôle
de période
marie noëlle lienemann est ce que vous
comprenez ces précautions que prend le
gouvernement en cas de deuxième vague
pas de confinement mais d interdiction
ciblée est ce que c'est utile quand on
voit par exemple que l'épidémie peut
reprendre avec les derniers événements
en meurthe-et-moselle ciblées mais
décidée par qui parce que c'est toujours
le même problème
bon moi personnellement je pense que ce
qu'elle dit philippe bas pour le coup je
suis pas souvent d'accord avec lui tout
cas pas toujours et il a raison soit on
sort de l'état d'urgence on rentre dans
le droit commun mais il ya toujours la
possibilité dans le droit commun s'il ya
un problème quelque part de prendre une
mesure et en particulier entre s'il ya
un travail sérieux avec le parlement de
pouvoir très rapidement de libérer s'il
ya besoin de modifier on est pas mal de
situations exceptionnelles cette crise
sanitaire dont on mai et prévoit revient
les un deuxième à l'union européenne ils
ont pas d'état d'urgence
donc ils vivent quand même ils ont pris
des mesures quand même et qu'on arrête
de nous faire croire que dans ce pays on
n'a pas d'outils pour agir quand il ya
un problème majeur qui se pose quelque
part c'est pas vrai donc là il ya un
problème espèce de culture de
généraliser l'état d'urgence je vous
rappelle qu'une partie au moment du
terrorisme partie des mesures dites
d'urgence sont fini par rentrer dans le
droit commun et on voit bien comment
petit à petit toutes leurs 2020
d'ailleurs 1 cm largeur de l'état
d'urgence ce securitas jusqu'en 2020
voilà un excellent qu'il en soit de même
sept mois moi personne non mais alors là
attendez dessous parle de lancer un sur
le twin de jaber
là cette fois ci non mais c'est chaque
fois 2020 puis après c'est encore plus
longtemps puis au cas où on sait jamais
non il faut que le droit français et il
est applicable pour les situations de
vous accuser ce gouvernement finalement
depuis à 2017 puis la loi sylt de porter
atteinte aux libertés publiques
je pense que petit à petit on grignote
sur les libertés publiques
je pense aussi qu'on grignote plus qu
grignote on affaiblit le parlement et
ont fait croire que c'est par un coup de
redonnant ce d'ailleurs pas seulement
sur ces sujets de d'urgence
c'est l'exécutif qui sait mieux sam on a
vu l'exécutif 1 il ya quand même eu
d'énormes d'énormes dysfonctionnements
pour ne pas dire de fautes et d'erreurs
donc le non ça n'est pas une faiblesse
d'associer le parlement aux décisions
publiques et en particulier quand il
s'agit des libertés où il faut tremblay
quand on modifie nous loi sur ce sujet
c'est une tentation convoi dans la
plupart des pays
parce que comme le libéralisme créer un
système d' inégalités accrues de
violences accrues de violence sociale
mais aussi de violences
d'autres violences mais la réponse et il
faut absolument à projet de loi il avait
pour but d'interdire les rassemblements
de l'udc de pouvoir confiné c'était une
erreur le confinement moi je pense que
le confinement était la conséquence pour
une large part en tout cas le
confinement généralisée et est la
conséquence d'un curry au début de la
pandémie et jal était auparavant parce
que la france ne s'était pas bien
préparé y a pas que la responsabilité de
cette exécrable seulement à des jeux
rappelle comme elle aime j'avais souvent
protester contre les politiques
d'austérité budgétaire notamment dans le
domaine de la santé ou de la protection
et en particulier quand on avait soi
disant pour des rationalités de
fonctionnement réunit toutes les
instances qui était censé faire le suivi
sanitaire du pays
on a supprimé les us ou lapsus je sais
plus quel était son nom exact et du coup
on sait on a perdu des outils d' alerte
et de préparation donc moi je pense que
le confinement
il aurait pu être moins long peut être
plus circonscrit dans la géographie est
en tout cas il est plus l'incurie que le
manque d'outils
juridiques pour agir en revenir sur le
régime dérogatoire sur les quatre
prochains mois
vous avez des craintes sur la liberté de
manifester ont longtemps déjà
l'opposition entend les regarder
l'histoire des infirmières qui voulait
faire grève ou les paramédicaux qui
veulent faire grève le 16 le 16 on
interdit les manifestations
ils manifestent tous les jeudis à
aujourd'hui la loi autorise une excuse
la loi elle est pas là pour être à
géométrie variable
on a le droit ou n'a pas le droit donc
il fallait revenir dire le rassemblement
non pour jon voight le non non je dis
simplement que c'est pas la peine
d'aller faire une loi pour dire qu'on va
alterner on peut toujours interdire une
manifestation trouble à l'ordre public
y a pas besoin d'avoir une loi d'urgence
si le préfet considère qu' à troubler
l'ordre public parce qu'il ya une menace
sanitaire ces troubles à l'ordre public
il n'y a pas besoin de cela d'ailleurs
ils se gênent pas pour les interdire
mais je lui dis je dis je vois bien la
pression qui a pour essayer de tuer les
mouvements sociaux ou alors on donne le
sentiment qu'on laisse faire et que la
loi peut elle s'applique à géométrie
variable
l'émotion n'est pas ça les règles
juridiques à double assassinat 067
tardez pas acceptable accepta et salué
par une partie de la gauche qui a dit
moi moi je pense que les règles
juridiques doivent permettre que
l'émotion s'exprime et là on met des
règles juridiques inadaptée qu'on
respecte pas et après eh bien comment
les expliquer que c'est selon que vous
serez puissant ou misérable
circonstances l'état de l'opinion
non les lois les les règles de jolis
doivent permettre à l'émotion populaire
de s'exprimer si je comprends bien vous
ne voterez pas ce projet de loi visant à
anéantir l'état d'urgence sanitaire
c'est je suis pour sortir mais je suis
contre les dérogations
donc je voterai la sortie sans les
dérogations et si on m'oblige à bouter
les des ambitions sans doute sur vous en
tout cas je ne voudrais pas aller au
poursuit cette émission avec dans
l'actualité également au parlement
l'annoncent par l'elysée de mission d'
enquête indépendante pour évaluer la
gestion de la crise sanitaire
[Musique]
l'objectif de ces missions porter un
regard indépendant et transparent sur la
situation et à avoir un retour
d'expérience explique l'exécutif
un but qui froisse les sénateurs ce
dernier lance d'ailleurs les travaux de
leur commission denquête fin juin jérôme
brasier l'elysée a soigneusement fait
fuiter l'information aux médias
l'exécutif souhaite lancer sa propre
commission d' enquête sur la gestion de
la crise l'objectif de cette troisième
commission serait de porter un regard
indépendant et transparent sur la
gestion de la crise par l'exécutif est
d'avoir un retour d'expérience dans sa
dimension sanitaire
ce qui a fait bondir le président du
sénat gérard larcher qui évoque sur les
réseaux sociaux sa stupéfaction en
apprenant la nouvelle
il aurait même d'abord cru à une fake
news mais depuis cette annonce le
gouvernement fait bloc et défend l'idée
d'un retour d'expérience courant dans le
monde de l'entreprise
je suis très surprise parce que si nous
n'avions pas nous-mêmes travailler à
améliorer nos processus de décision tout
le monde se serait écrié que c'est
scandaleux et après je veux dire il y a
le temps de l'exécutif il y a le temps
des parlementaires autant dire que du
côté des parlementaires de l'opposition
l'initiative fait bondir pour le futur
président de la commission d' enquête
sénatoriale
c'est un scandale institutionnels c'est
un geste antidémocratique de première
grandeur il y à l'assemblée nationale
qui a sa propre commission denquête le
sénat qui a la sienne me semble que
c'est largement suffisant en tout cas la
construction avait prévu la liberté des
parlementaires sur le sujet même
indignation à la gauche de l'hémicycle
pour le patron du groupe socialiste au
sénat cela va laisser des traces dans
les relations parlement exécutif ça peut
être aussi un acte de défiance du
gouvernement à l'égard du parlement
alors que le parlement a été tout à fait
à la hauteur depuis le début de cette
crise et donc c'est tout à fait dommage
d'autant que la commission denquête de
l'exécutif veut aller vite très vite
même avec un rapport prévu cet été
les parlementaires rendront eux leurs
conclusions d'ici la fin de l'année en
espérant montrer que l'indépendance du
parlement permettra un véritable bilan
de l'action du gouvernement pendant
cette période et précisons que selon le
canard enchaîné il va y avoir deux miss
ils ont une mission d'experts
scientifiques et un audit financier de
la cour des comptes
marie noëlle lienemann est ce que c'est
une bonne chose parce que ce n'est pas
complémentaire par rapport aux
commissions d'enquêté parlementaires que
cette initiative de l'exécutif ou de
l'art de noyer le poisson parce que
emmanuel macron elle gouvernements
savent qu'ils ont une large part de
responsabilité dans le non pas le
déclenchement du virus c'est clair mais
la manière dont la france ne s'est pas
armé de manière opérationnelle et n'a
pas tenu un discours de vérité aux
français
ce rappelez vous l'histoire ne faut pas
mettre de masse ça sert à rien à l'été
ça sert à rien enfin bon bref on connaît
tout cela c'était en fait nous dit noyer
le poisson mais la commission attendait
les 30 secondes noyer le poisson parce
que toul arles
tout l'art veille de donner des messages
tous azimuts pour dire dans tout se vaut
il ya du pour y à du compte on sait y
avait personne n'est responsable de rien
et ça va accroître la crise démocratique
premièrement qu'est ce qu'ils ont dit
sur les commissions d'enquêté de
l'assemblée c'est que ce n'était pas
elle n'était pas impartiale et
indépendante
mais la meilleure indépendance c'est le
pluralisme
c'est le fait que dans cette commission
vous ayez des gens de tous bords
politiques représentant le pays
deuxièmement elles sont transparentes
toutes les auditions son public il n'ya
pas le confinement entre les gens du
même milieu qui discutent entre elles
on sent et on voit bien qu'il ya un
travail très important de relations
entre l'opinion publique et le parlement
on l'a vu dans d'autres commissions
dockett il ya des gens qui réagissent
sur les réseaux sociaux qui nous
appellent en dix ans pour qu'on faisait
pas poser telle question donc ça permet
de nourrir le débat
le train une instrumentalisation
politique finalement 2 mais on a tous en
tête la sphère benalla des excuses la
règle et en quoi ce instrumentaliser
politiquement benalla on a fait notre le
le sénat fait son travail dgt a transmis
aux à la justice c'est pas lui qui juge
la justice a rendu son jugement le
rappel de lignes à haute tension qui
avait eu entre l'exécutif et le
parlement à cette occasion mais vous
croyez eu des stigmates dans les
relations entre l'inde et mais on s'en
moque des relations c'est les citoyens
qui ont besoin de savoir
il faut qu'on sache que ce qui s'est
passé qu est-ce qui a dysfonctionné
deuxièmement les retours d'expérience il
se trouve que j'étais ministre au moment
de l'explosion
rien de là l'explosion azf à toulouse et
on le voit dans le rapport heureusement
qu'il ya la commission d' enquête sur
lubrizol
ah oui sur pourquoi et comment etc parce
que qu'est-ce qui se passe il faut en
effet l'administration elle-même les
l'administration c'est à dire l'état qui
normalement n'est pas totalement vendu
100 % au gouvernement il ya une certaine
neutralité doit rendre des comptes et
expliquer son retour d'expérience propre
mais cela n'empêche pas l'autre les
mairies en espérant que ce bon il fait
les commissions ont également augmenté
non non l'exécutif doit faire travailler
son administration d'un truc et c'est
pas l'elysée qui gouverne le pays
c'est le premier minis l'usam ans cette
initiative allait contraire aux
institutions moi je trouve qu'elle elle
parasite elle elle cherche à noyer le
poisson pour éviter les responsabilités
et faire que tout se vaut deux elle
discrédite le parlement et notamment son
côté pluraliste qui garantit plus
d'indépendance que tout autre parce que
les autres ils vont être nommés par le
président vous croyez qu'ils vont nommer
des gens qui vont être très hostile à
leur politique non et par ailleurs sa
tube l'idée d'un état qui est porteur de
l'intérêt général avec une certaine
neutralité qui lui même avec tous les
défauts que je trouve un haut
fonctionnaire technocrates et autres
doit pouvoir expliquer aux citoyens son
retour d'expérience en tant qu'etat en
lien évidemment avec l'exécutif
mais en tant qu'etat et c'est dans la
confrontation de ces trois regards que
nous devons quitte à ce que l'état
demande et des scientifiques des regards
croisés mais c'est à travers ces trois
regards que les français doivent pouvoir
et à l'exécutif qu'il y aura un
benchmark avec les autres pays ce que
nous pensons qu'elle n'a pas dans une
entreprise le benchmark est à notre pays
vous êtes vous ai appris que c'est une
pandémie c'est une crise mondiale on
perd pas pouvoir vous croyez que le
sénat il parlement vont pas regarder ce
qui s'est passé ailleurs ils vont
auditionner aussi des personnels et bien
ça nous arrive très souvent de
l'auditionner
mais en plus regarder comment comparer
la suède et la france la suède c'est
gros comme ronald pendant d'habitants et
s'est étalé sur un territoire très vaste
pourquoi le coc vite s'est pas déplacé
en allemagne avec la montre s'est recalé
décision allemande
il ya aussi
si je puis dire on pourrait dire la
moitié de la france ouest
elle est vachement bien organisés tandis
que la moitié est c'est vraiment des
menaces puisque il ya eu essentiellement
sur l'est le coc vide est beaucoup moins
son l'ouest on voit bien qu'il ya
d'autres critères que simplement parce
que vous êtes français parce que machin
est le système il ya des choses à tirer
quand ça marche bien quelque part
par exemple c'est inacceptable que
l'indépendance en matière de tests en
matière de matériel
l'allemagne on est davantage que la
france ça il n'y a pas besoin de 25
mille experts étrangers pour vous le dit
précisons que d'ailleurs à la commission
d' enquête du sénat prévoit des
déplacements en allemagne pour rien su
de comparaison on voit quand même leur
est maintenant vraiment aux critiques
est-ce que tout de même il ne faudrait
pas renouer avec une part de l'unité
nationale qui est apparu au plus fort de
la crise y compris dans ce moment pour
bien penser à la prêt pour bien faire le
bilan aussi de cette période mais il
faut cei le français le principe même de
la raison en france c'est le regard
critique sur le réel et la capacité de
nous mobiliser autour de projets communs
c'est ça qu'il faut qu'on fasse et
l'unité c'est pas faire l'autruche
ferment on va pas se fâcher les gars
tout va bien non fou avec lucidité sans
acrimonie excessive mais avec une
lucidité absolue est en tout cas des
points de vue absolue deuxièmement oui
je suis pour une mobilisation générale
mais on ne mobilise pas les français
autour d'un unique d'un unanimisme
béland derrière le chef l exécutif on
est encore plus quand on voit que toute
une série de nos concitoyens reste les
oubliés des politiques publiques alors
qu'ils sont souvent les propositions
entre un gouvernement d'union nationale
n'a pas de sens
il faut que le débat ait lieu mais on
peut être mobilisé en débattant qu'est
ce que c'est que cette idée qu'il
faudrait être on n'est pas en n'est pas
l'armée et encore quand on discute
l'armée aux intrus quand même mais on
n'est pas je ne veux voir qu'une seule
tête au contraire où toutes les énergies
se sentent utiles à l'avenir du pays que
tous ceux qui ont des projets envie de
faire qui ont envie de se former que
l'on vide puisse se sentir partie
prenante des énergies qui vont être bien
utile et nécessaire puisqu'on va
maintenant s'intéresser à la crise
économique conséquence de l'épidémie de
covin et de trois un troisième projet de
loi de finances rectificative a été
présenté cette semaine en conseil des
ministres dans la foulée bruno le maire
a défendu ce nouveau budget en
commission alors en dépit des milliards
prévus pour relancer l'économie
un consensus politique ne semble pas se
dégager l amende à gaza un troisième
collectif budgétaire pour faire face à
la crise sanitaire devenue crise
économique je rappelle que l'ensemble
des sommes qui sont consacrés à cette
réponse avec les économique représente
avec ce plfr 3 460 milliards d'euros
c'est 20 % de la richesse nationale
française c'est l'équivalent du produit
national brut de l'autriche c'est donc
une réponse massive et je le redis
efficace qui étaient apportées à cette
crise dans ce budget rectificatif 45
milliards d'euros pour les secteurs les
plus fragilisées 18 milliards pour le
tourisme 15 milliards d'euros pour
l'aéronautique ou encore 8 milliards
d'euros pour le plan automobile
pour ce troisième projet de loi de
finances rectificative en trois mois la
droite réclame dorénavant un cap
globalement où va-t-on quand on a quand
on est face à des chiffres de cette
ampleur ce serait assez important
peut-être de conduire le pays vers un
tout petit peu plus de lucidité vous
égrainé des plans sectoriels je le
comprends les secteurs qui souffrent le
plus il faut évidemment le faire mais où
est la vision d'ensemble
les oppositions de gauche elle propose
une taxation des plus hauts revenus
il me semblait qu'en période
exceptionnelle on était en droit de
demander un effort exceptionnel une
contribution exceptionnelle aux plus
aisés nous aurions préféré que cet
argent public investi trouvent le moyen
de faire contribuer un peu plus le
capital financier à l'effort réclamé à
toute la nation les prévisions
économiques pour cette année s'aggrave à
nouveau le déficit s'élèverait à 11,4
pour cent du pib
marie noëlle lienemann 460 milliards
d'euros ont jusqu'ici été injectés dans
l'économie qu'est ce que vous pensez
de la gestion de la crise en matière
d'économie par ce gouvernement
je crois qu'il fallait injecter
massivement de l'argent public je me
réjouis d'ailleurs qu'on découvre que
l'euro l'état a un rôle économique
majeur et pas seulement et c'est là des
réflexions il faudra avoir même sur la
mise en oeuvre du plan s'est pas
seulement la voiture balai quand le
système va pas pour qu'ensuite on
empoche les profits et les bénéfices
quand ça va mieux en certains empochent
les profits elle donc premièrement
d'accord avec ces stratégies
deuxièmement je vois bien poindre avec
les propos de monsieur woerth
la bonne vieille rengaine de la gauche
de la droite par ton contre la gauche
faute ou faudra arriver faut être
prudent faudra faire de l'austérité
faudra revenir jamais vraiment pensé
dans le débat de la dette parce qu'on
sait tous bégué on vous pose et non pour
une raison simple c'est l'histoire de la
france est faite de dette de la france
du monde est faite de dettes non
remboursées alors on étale dans la durée
je veux pas rentrer dans la technique je
veux dire les manques il ya aujourd'hui
à ce qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
terrible pour une partie des français
c'est sur le cap social première
premièrement tous ces chômeurs qui ne
sont pas indemnisés qu'on appelle les
intermittents de l'emploi
c'est un million deux cent mille voire
amis ont cinq cent mille de personnes
qui n'ont rien
c'est à dire qu'ils sont indemnisés de
rien parce qu'ils étaient extras dans le
bâtiment l'hôtel un essai marqué
notamment par les dispositifs de chômage
partiel ils ont été très généreux
vous êtes mettez tout de même que ce
type de dispositif elles ne peuvent pas
continuer à fulham aeternam advitam
eternam certainement pas plus longtemps
jusqu'en septembre octobre
oui tous les économistes montrent que
c'est un mécanisme qui est à la fois
pourvoyeur de pouvoir d'achat maintient
les gens dans l'entreprise et permet aux
entreprises de rigaud d'essayer de
limiter la casse mais qui les routes
ben oui ça coûte mais ça coûte aussi 15
milliards quand pour l'automobile etc
oui ça coûte en revanche il faut bien
contrôlée qui a pas d'abus ça je pense
que le gouvernement a dit conscient
qu'il offrirait bien il y en a marre en
jeu le ville en est il ya une urgence
absolue au chômage à l'indemnisation du
chômage des intermittents du spectacle
la première panne du spectacle justement
de l'emploi parce que ceux du spectacle
sont réglés pas les autres
et ceux là sont très fragiles où vous ne
demandez mon avis elle vous dit
finalement les traiter de ce forum
seconde laissez-moi terminée il ya 2 16
30 secondes à wisches et bien mais
justement pour moi c'est important
deuxièmement les jeunes il faut mettre
le rsa pour les jeunes tout de suite
troisièmement il faut mieux conditionner
les aides en tout cas faire un accord
pour que les n de relance industrielle
permettent la mutation pas de fermeture
de site
on doit travailler à la mutation des
sites industriels existants et enfin
faire contribuer les plus riches
les mouvements financiers et les gaffes
à à la relance de notre pays beaucoup
marie noëlle lienemann c'est le mot de
la fin merci beaucoup à tout d'abord
c'est à cette émission
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
un nouveau numéro de parlement hebdo
[Musique]